So this is what a typical
frame looks like for
as developers when things
are more than just a static page.
It looks like the pipeline
I talked about just before
except I've now chucked
JavaScript at the front.
Normally, you're going to use
JavaScript to handle work
that will result in visual changes.
Whether it's jQuery's animate function,
sorting a data set, or
adding DOM elements to the page.
But you don't have to use JavaScript for
your visual changes.
In fact, for
many applications developers use
CSS animations, transitions, or
even the new Web Animations API to
make visual changes to their page.
Now with that out of the way, we can
talk about the pipeline a bit more.
The changes we make here won't
necessarily trigger every part
of the pipeline either.
In fact, there are three ways
the pipeline normally plays out for
a given frame.
So let's talk about those for a second.
So number one, you make a visual
change either with CSS Or JavaScript.
The browser must recalculate the styles
of the elements that were affected.
Now if you changed a layout property, so
that's one that changed an element's
geometry like its width, height, or
position with relation to another
element like left or top,
then the browser will have to check all
the other elements and re-flow the page.
Any affected areas will
need to be repainted.
And the final painted elements will
need to be composited back together.
The second way the pipeline gets used is
when you change a paint only property,
like background image,
text color, or shadows.
This time, we make the change,
the styles are calculated,
we don't do layout because we didn't
change the geometry of any elements.
We do paint and we do composite.
And the last way involves changing
something that requires neither layout,
nor paint, just compositing.
Compositing is where the browser
puts the individual layers
of the page together.
And that requires layer management to
ensure we have the right layers, and
in the correct order.
So we make our change.
We do style calculations,
but we only do composite.
You probably noticed that
style was always included for
each of those variations.
Different styles affect which
parts of the pipeline we touch?
And therefore the performance
characteristics of our apps.